Senator Tom Cotton tearing into Kroger's
boss for asking the GOP for help to stop
Democrats planned regulations after the
chain recently silenced conservative
employees
I've cautioned them for years that if
they silence
conservatives and Center rights voters
across the country if they discriminate
against them in their company they
probably shouldn't come and ask
Republican Senators to carry the water
for them whenever our Democratic friends
want to regulate them or block their
mergers I'll say this I'm sorry that's
happening to you best of luck but Disney
doesn't seem to be taking the threat
seriously despite the promise to quiet
things down on the culture wars Disney's
top dog Bob Iger says people in power
have a quote extra responsibility to
push gun control now I you know what
Dana I first want to address the concept
of Tom Cotton getting out there and
saying you know what we're going to
start drawing the lines in the sand you
know
you expect us to help you when you're
constantly in this case apparently there
were two employees of Kroger's who were
conservatives who got fired uh because
of their beliefs and then they go to
tomcat and say we want your help is that
the way to run businesses and it had I
think that the divorce with the
Republican party in Corporate America
had been brewing for some time and I
think it really reached a fever pitch
when Georgia's passed the new voting
laws and then all of a sudden you had
companies like Delta Coca-Cola Major
League Baseball
um Coke I mentioned Coca-Cola by
financial institutions they said that
that was a racist vote suppressor in
Georgia and then remember MLB moved out
and then they hadn't even read the bill
right and but they will come to the
Republicans and say oh my gosh you got
to help us you wouldn't believe what
these crazy liberals want to do they
want to regulate us they're not going to
be able to do business we're gonna have
to lay off people we're not going to be
competitive in the world we need the
Republicans to help us in somebody like
Tom Cotton saying guys you're gonna have
to pay attention here and either choose
to run a business or to be political but
you're not going to be able to do both
and come to me you know Harold when uh
Bob chapek the head of Disney you know
got into that alleged don't say gay law
in Florida Ron DeSantis took it quite
seriously and now chapic is gone but now
Bob Iger comes in and says he's got his
own culture war going on why don't the
heads of Corporations stay in their Lane
and do what they do and let the
politicians deal with the other stuff
uh because I think that we live in a
society where everybody feels that
they're a part of what's happening and
everyone sees what's happening look I
think the Disney CEO has a right to
freedom of speech uh and if the
shareholders and others and around that
company the board doesn't want that CEO
they can excuse the seal much like they
did Miss iger's predecessor I'm I
thought you were going to go a different
direction with Tom Khan I'm a little I
was disappointed in Tom Khan I think he
is on paper as qualified as any person a
servant ascendant he's a veteran uh he's
a Harvard educated Harvard trained uh
guy he's conservative I'm not
conservative
um but the the logic doesn't make sense
to me you don't shoot you cannot say to
a constituent of yours or a constituency
I'm mad at you it's like a
seven-year-old so I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna listen even though I agree with
you I'm so mad at you I can't help you
now if you don't agree with them that's
one thing if you philosophically say I
think that's the wrong thing to cut
taxes I think that's the wrong team
wrong thing to have less regulations in
your industry I think it's the wrong
thing to help you compete innovate and
win against China but if all you're
saying is you're mad it reminded me when
Governor DeSantis who's an impressive
guy himself and when he said he wouldn't
go on The View because he thought those
hosts were really mean if you can't
handle the value you can't handle China
and for Tom Cotton I hope I hope he
steps back well he said it he was the
one that said I'm not going I'm not
going to subject myself
if you're I was in Congress I never said
to my Republican constituents if you
call the office and you want help with
your passport or you want help with a
constituent matter I'm not going to do
it because I'm mad at you if they called
and said we want you to vote for a bill
that would allow more people to have
guns I'd say you know what I don't want
to do that he was wrong okay and what he
said I think you agree with that but the
question is and and what Harold's
talking about Jesse is why not take
advantage of the opportunity but doesn't
it indicate that we are so far down the
road that you know Democrats don't do
anything to help Republicans and the
Republicans are saying it's our turn all
these politicians are totally bought off
by these companies anyway they've been
talking such a big game about what
they're going to do to Big Tech we're
going to break up big Tech how many was
that a decade they've been saying that
how many years have we heard they're
going to raise taxes on the hedge funds
how many years do they ever do it they
never do it oh we're gonna go after a
big Pharma big Pharma pays a fine breaks
the law pays a fine breaks the law what
are they going to break up a mergers
maybe they break up one or two mergers
lawyers will get paid lobbyists still
get paid they just reapply to merge when
there's a different Administration in
there this is what happens you get a
senator who's mad they come to the
center oh really you have a problem why
doesn't your sister-in-law join our
board and every quarter will fly her out
it doesn't matter don't disclose it it's
off the books and and the stock options
they're transferable oh you still have a
problem because we'll just fund your
primary opponent oh you know what now
that I think about it you look like you
need a vacation I mean a fact-finding
mission we're going to fly to Nicaragua
and you'll have one meeting about an
environmental impact study and the rest
of the time you can golf at the resort
that's how it works Harold and you were
there and you know better than anybody I
missed out on this yeah
everywhere and you know it they have an
army
lobbyists thank you carpet bomb these
politicians they could do something but
they don't
I would I would I disagree mildly with
Harold I think that yes it does come off
cotton does come off almost as a little
kind of snotty or turlish except that
what he's working for is persuasion for
the next opportunity I think he's trying
to say look you know we'll try working
with us and we'll work with you but
right now it kind of sucks but
I think it's the igers of the world who
are the real selfish jerks because they
don't understand what's happening to
their employees it sucks for these
employees at these companies because
like the top executives are virtue
signaling or chasing ESG policies or
they're all just trying to cover their
butts from a media that is looking at
them they want to make sure that they
appear compassionate to the media who
are very woke so they don't write about
my bonus right because remember that's
all they ever write about corporations
is like so and so just got seven million
dollars in bonus they it's so much
better if they say the CEO you know
published a book on you know uh
intersectionality but and you think
that's what but then what happens is the
brand becomes toxic which is what
happened with with uh Disney and now is
what's happening with American Doll
right they tried to soften you know
everybody knows that American Doll is
very popular but they're overpriced it's
like a rip-off I mean this is why I no
longer buy my furniture there because
like you know just a tiny little oven
will cost like 200 so anyway my point
being they tried to soften their appeal
by doing this little book telling kids
how to transition you know yeah and it's
like you know they're running now I
don't even know if they're even
responding American Girl responding I
think they're hiding and you know
because
let's go over yeah you need some new
clothes
we should just walk over and knock on
the door I mean can you believe a dog
company is talking to kids about you
know the transitioning